here now senator lindsey graham member
of the judiciary committee all right
senator can you call the white house and
maybe get him a message about some of
these things i'm advising him to do
i don't think anybody's at home
so
here's the deal
it's one thing to hurt putin and
shutting down nordstrom 2 hurts putin
it's a cash cows a pipeline that goes
into germany from russia goes around
ukraine and that's a lot of money for
putin and a lot of guests for the
germans i'm glad they're shutting the
damn thing down but it doesn't help you
here at home you want to help the
american people let's become energy
independent again why can't we open up
keystone pipeline let's have a vote in
the united states senate and put
democrats on record who want to keep the
pipeline shut down why can't we go back
to aggressive fracking and unfreeze what
you just said limitations on exploring
for all oil and gas here at home we are
sitting on
an abundance of american-owned oil and
gas
and we should be exploiting it for our
purposes and helping our allies we
should be all in with energy
independence but no we're getting our
ass kicked overseas and biden's getting
let around by his nose here at home by
the left we're not going to secure a
border because he had pissed off aoc
we're not going to drill for oil and gas
that we own because the environmental
left owns the guy and putin is kicking
his ass in the ukraine and i will tell
you this jesse uh you're a good guy but
if we get screwed over in ukraine the
world and let putin get away with it
china's going into taiwan and iran's
going to get a nuclear weapon so one
thing does lead to the other so what
would you do right now if you were
sitting in the white house you're the
commander-in-chief senator lindsey
graham looks like he's going in hard any
day now what do you know new people
well here i would i would open up
keystone production tomorrow no but in
europe would declare uh put
in europe
what would i do i would start exporting
liquefied uh natural gas from america to
europe i would tell the europeans that
we're going to go after putin's assets
let's do something new the guy's the
richest one of the richest people in the
world because he steals the russian
people blind let's take his oligarchs
all of his buddies take their rich
apartments away from them sell their
yachts and put them in jail for being
war profiteers you know what i would do
if i were president united states i
would declare putin an international war
criminal because he's abating invading a
neighboring nation that signed an
agreement with russia in 1994 to give up
their nuclear stockpile ukraine with a
promise they wouldn't get invaded that
putin broke that promise and he needs to
pay a price personally i would go all in
with energy independence and i would
kick our friends and they asked for not
helping us in europe now that sounds
pretty tough and i i respect that
opinion
how would you cool things down though
because seizing apartments and making
them an international war criminal i
feel like gas is going to probably hit
ten dollars a gallon if we do something
like that how would you simmer things
down and keep things cool
stateside
well uh
there's no way to disconnect us from you
know but this whole idea that what
happens europe doesn't matter to us
remember war one and world war ii it's
clear to me that putin is going after
more than ukraine the ukraine is a
democracy he's dismembering the
democracy he's going he's going to take
the entire country over and china's
watching what he's doing and if taiwan
falls that's where all the chips in the
world were pretty much made china would
own taiwan so the iranians i was spent
three days in israel they're worried to
death that biden doesn't have the
backbone to stop the ayatollah who wants
a nuclear bomb he's a religious nazi
he's not getting a bomb to protect the
iranian people he's getting a bomb to
enact his religious
religious agenda which means to kill all
the jews and the infidels so i don't
know how to be nice about this
i don't know how much more we have to
suffer as a nation and let bad guys kick
us in the ass and lose control of our
own destiny here at home so i don't know
of a nice way to stand up to thugs last
question real quick if he goes after a
nato country do we send soldiers there
and bail out estonia or lithuania or
something like that
uh we better because we've we made a
promise to all of our nato allies an
attack on one is attack on all i'd like
to remind you my friend after 9 11
article 5 was invoked for the first time
in the history of nato on our behalf so
if you let putin get away with this and
china get away with it and iran get away
with it you'll be in a third world war
and you'll have a bunch of radical
islamists with nuclear weapons that's
why you need to control your border
remember world war ii this didn't work
out well then it's not going to work out
well now i miss donald trump if donald
trump were president none of this crap
would be going on because you got to be
strong when you're weak is when
everything falls apart and biden is weak
and trump was strong i hope we have
another election soon all right senator
lindsey graham thank you so much for
joining jesse waters from
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else